vocês são demais
mas um novo brasileiro carioca favelado
entrou para as estatísticas
atraído iludido sem nenhuma alternativa
encurralado num beco sem saída
mas quem disse que ele nasceu pra viver
assim
quem disse que ele escolheu esse caminho
de ajj lutar guerra sem fim é só
violência fome miséria para muitos que
vivem aqui the age luta guerra sem fim é
só violência fome miséria para muitos
que vivem aqui toda a nossa história
contada nas escolas não passam de uma
mentira
nós sentimos sagradas e os negros
escravizados por um país colonialista a
história do brasil começou assim faz
tempos que sofremos tudo isso de ajj
luta guerra fim só violência fome
miséria pra muitos que vivem aqui the
age luta' guerra sem fim
só violência fome miséria para muitos
que vivem aqui
valeu gente é só a música da minha
autoria que retrata exatamente tudo
aquilo que eu não acredito eu não nasci
pra isso eu rompi a kibon tac está aqui
com vocês
que bom compartilhar experiências que a
gente vem lá do rio de janeiro do rio de
janeiro que a maioria de vocês aqui não
conhece hoje o rio de janeiro de jessé
binho cultura é totalmente o é diferente
do rio de janeiro que você vê na
televisão podem acreditar mas você está
andando com a gente lá na cidade você
gostar muito bom acompanhar
esses caras são de machucar então assim
vai servir o que o g7 é chapa quente e é
interessante aqui
a ana conseguiu colocar nesse palco aqui
no mesmo dia dos caras com histórias
muito parecidas que moram na mesma
região do rio de janeiro
ela talvez não soubesse disso e diárias
que são totalmente rivais
então lá até um tempo atrás eu não podia
entrar na área dele não pôde entrar na
minha área e aí assim não essa coisa de
derrubar é pênalti não é ou mesmo assim
é da área dele dominada por uma facção
rival à área que domina a minha região
só que nós decidimos escrever a nossa
história diferente
o roteiro que estava desenhado para nós
é mais ou menos assim você nasce cresce
e produz quando consegue reproduzir
claro morre sem você tenta sair do
daquele quadrado e que bom estar aqui
nesse redonda
esse tapete vermelho chamou moral para a
gente mesmo é chamado com isso igual na
palestra de ontem lada da gelada
tailândia a rainha lá também maneira a
gente tem esse tapetinho que estava
ligado mas ontem é tudo me marcou muito
a ouvir a experiência do ver a sua
experiência ao lista foi fantástico
a emoção que o bial nos trouxe na
infância me resgatou todo o início da
minha história
filho de doméstica o marceneiro
nascido e criado na vila aliança e um
sub bairro de bangu
o primeiro conjunto habitacional da
américa latina
fruto das remoções as primeiras remoções
de favelas no rio de janeiro onde
pessoas foram arrancadas de seus shows
das suas casas e levadas para um lugar
como já falou duas horas do centro da
cidade duas horas para tudo e hoje em
dia com o do jeito que tá tudo caótico
três horas de cessar entrassem cara eu
tive que sair quatro horas da manhã pra
chegar no aeroporto para pegar o vôo de
nove só para não correr o risco de
chegar atrasado então assim foi mais ou
menos quatro horas até o aeroporto assim
é muita coisa
a gente sofre tudo isso mas a história
estava desenhada para mim e eu rompi o
seguinte eu acho quatro anos de idade
aprendi a ler
se eu fosse filho de rico eu seria um
menino prodígio mas aí enfim a senhora o
menino maneira em que a era a família a
porta à venda ele sai da falei ah ah ah
então recebe essas coisas eu era
engraçadinho da família também o
primeiro universitário
ao contrário do renato falou aqui em
terceiro lugar está a formação da sua
família eu fui o primeiro e agora como
vai montar lá não é fácil não é fácil
eu vim aqui para falar de sonhos sonhos
e realizações são aqueles em que a mãe
recebe em dia não é assim
mas o sonho que a gente dentro da favela
durante muitos anos não se deu ao luxo
de sonhar porque nossos avós nossos
nossos bisavós nossos pais tinham que
ralar muito tiveram que ralar muito para
da gente uma condição de vulnerável como
mostrou o renato ou de pobre ou de
extremamente pobre e aí a criação de
referência dentro do nosso território é
cada vez mais distante
distante porque porque essas pessoas que
geralmente ascende socialmente
economicamente
a primeira coisa que elas fazem a sair
da favela
e aí o espaço da favela territórios do
território de comunidades populares é
sempre um lugar de tentar tentando
tentando tentando que quando consegue e
não volta
então quando um salto enorme na minha
história sem ter menino que gostava de
ler e tal jardim de infância dos três
irmãos foram que tive acesso
eu não tinha livro em casa e aí como que
esse paradoxo de você gostar de ler de
você gostar de livros mas não pelo livro
em casa em casa década de 80 ainda e
finalzinho de ditadura todo mundo duro
e aí a gente eu me lembro que há uma
grande lembrança eu tinha que a gente
tinha geladeira ea geladeira dava choque
tanto assim na geladeira da gente já
tinha água então num razão toma choque
mesmo então assim é mas o que eu mais
gostava livro eu não sei porque talvez
eu saiba eu tinha meu pai que sempre lia
jornal não vai jogando até hoje todos os
jornais não pode todo dia para compra
jornal pode faltar o pão mas o jornal
não falta
minha mãe da bíblia em casa não tinha
livro então o que eu fazia ou via ouvia
leitores de livros mas eram leitores e
minha mãe minha mãe avó pedagoga do
mundo
ela é minha quinta série mas a minha mãe
ela falava no filho a visão do da mãe
está cansada
nessa parte da bíblia aqui pra mamãe eu
descobri que na bíblia tinha poesia e
cantares de salomão
assim acompanhar e também a notícia
esportiva para uma referência no esporte
lá onde a gente mora porque não por um
seu jogador mas porque meu pai que fazer
os campos de futebol e um terreno baldio
então assim é uma espécie de 100 campo
entende que a mata tal capinava tudo e
fazia a yes os campos de futebol e
entretenimento e isso e de um programa
em causa um problema muito sério
eu sofri muito bullying por causa do meu
pai que acompanhava o pai nos jogos
então ele era o dono do time
ele era o dono do do jogo de camisa dono
da do campo dono da bola
isso não significa que eu era bom de
bola mas eu tinha vaga no time é o
seguinte eu era o líder da parada porque
o seguinte
o mec não meu amigo porque iam ter vaga
no time
mas eu era o pior dia em botar na zaga
foi o seguinte tentar botar em todas as
pontas mas não rolou com 12 anos eu
pendurei as chuteiras
e até hoje quando enquanto essa
rapaziada os que restaram porque uma boa
parte morreu e outro por tráfico e tal e
aí eu sofro bullying cacatu linha da
casa tomava vinho uma balançada
e aí eu fiquei num limbo porque eu não
era bom de bola e não tinha outra
alternativa dentro da da comunidade
e aí essa coisa toda de escrever a coisa
de mulherzinha
então se eu gostava de ver se no saque
eu gostava de colecionar papel de cartas
lá isso era muito comum entre as meninas
com 14 anos eu falei pô você emicídio
baile funk adianta jeito com essas
coisas aí só que a indústria lá era
muito perversa e tal
não achei falei cara também tem feito
nesse negócio
vou desistir até que um dia eu conheci
uma poesia uma poesia de verdade quando
olhei aquela poesia foi o meu concelho
negócio aqui tal fui lá nos cadernos e
compararam o txt2stop caracol escrevo
poesia eu sou poeta está infeliz da vida
que ou pela primeira vez na vida está
fazendo alguma coisa estava sendo poeta
isso com 14 anos de idade
mas a crise na minha família como essa
palavra crise está na moda então não
tinha 30 na minha família então assim
faltar umas coisas e aí meu pai e só
voltava ou porque não podia comprar a
bola são toda essa meu pai cassando de
futebol de samba e tal de saber como que
é minha mãe da igreja então meu pai
sempre escapava e a escapada escapava
ele não bebia mas o vício dele era
mulher
e aí faltou alguma coisa pra dedicado ea
gente entrou na adolescência lhe tiram a
roupa de marca queria chegar bonitinho
ea gente ainda tinha uma outra coisa que
aí o jorge falou aqui que ele era black
power
na minha infância e meu irmão agente era
black power porque não passou a cortar o
cabelo agente do fbi por ano trouxe à
tona eu nunca tenho orgulho da minha
foto de quando era criança quando
comecei a usar black power também
botaram o dread
deu para dar uma analisada mas aí eu
poder chamar a atenção do meu pai eu
comecei a pixar
mesmo assim e essa questão da pichação
era muito comum na década de 90 ea gente
usava com uma expressão de rebeldia
queria mandar um recado e eu só não
sabia o outro lado o lado glamoroso
disso então se dava mulher
isso te dá um status eu gostei da coisa
e assim mais uma vez me remetendo a
questão do deserto é muito comum você
envolve muito histórias parecidas com a
nossa de pessoas das escolas públicas
porque a gente passa batido e como o
bial falou ontem à escola ela acaba
travando o potencial artístico a sua
qualidade toda a sua liderança
por que não é culpa do professor é culpa
do sistema educacional que está obsoleta
e aí me tornar referência na escola e
tal respeitado até que um dia o zelador
da escola falou assim para mim a paz
o diretor vai esperar você só fazer uma
coisa ele vai expulsar bom você é
inteligente e vai ser um rapaz bacana
popular seu erro o zelador
eu esperava que o de qualquer professor
dia da direção da coordenação pedagógica
mas o zelador da escola ou por mim
olhei nos olhos dele abaixei a cabeça e
aquele ano mudou a minha vida mudou
minha vida já ali os 16 e os 17 anos eu
me tornei representante de turma
imagina o cara maior terrorista da
escola que o professor gosta disso de
pegasse uma bagunceiro essa estratégia
antiga cara tá se botar os prós e prós e
representante fui representante de turma
decepcionei escola inteira porque os
passeios o pessoal tocava de turma não
caracteriza uma turma do bingo aikau
aí quando chegava lá e rolar na primeira
o senhor fala direta
não não diferente do tse vai na direção
pega leve se lembra que e talvez um
office boy assim da sala e aí aquilo ali
funcionou até uma turma até chegar e a
escola poder falar pra mim a adira eu
comprei é a professora meu pai não pode
comprar livros para todas e sofri mais
duro golpe
assim para encerrar a minha adolescência
e essa participação na escola quando
confidencia a professora podia comprar
livro que sai pelo outro
ela falou não tudo bem você vem e aí
depois a gente é um livro emprestado pra
você
contei para ela toda a situação problema
foi a primeira vez que o desabafo feito
aqui naquele assunto estava muito bem em
casa agora você o melhor aluno da escola
aquela coisa toda
aí a professora depois disso pra turma
inteira e constrangendo e eu cheguei em
casa com o pai e minha mãe falou 'tá
vendo passar vergonha por que você tá
com meu pai valor e aí há males que vêm
para o bem
aquelas coisas de escrever e tal fez com
que as pessoas votassem na fala cara
você é muito inteligente mas é
diferenciado
você tem que voltar a estudar eu tinha
um sonho eu assisti muito programa do jô
soares que falava assim desde os 16 anos
onde eu vou lá ele vai entrevistar onde
eu vou lá um dia lá e aí eu com 18 anos
montou a primeira biblioteca comunitária
de onde a mãe meu irmão nem mais ninguém
vai passar a humilhação que eu passei
dez anos depois já formado em ciências
sociais tal fundei o primeiro centro
cultural lá de onde eu moro junto com
meu irmão caçula e também seguir o ritmo
e com outro amigo
fundamos o centro cultural a história
que eu conta
trabalhando a cultura para o
desenvolvimento e com o centro cultural
nós conseguimos tirar a violência dos
piores de gás da cidade do rio de
janeiro
conseguimos atrair o olhar do poder
público falar tem que investir aqui e
ali
então começamos em ter um poder
político entender aquilo que as pessoas
que irão procurar gente tudo respeitamos
chamava gente e aí
cinco anos depois dessa etapa de ter
alcançado muitos objetivos dentro do da
da vila aliança eu falei chegou a hora
de ocupar a zona oeste à zona com
potencial artístico cultural precisava
se enxergar e se livrado síndrome de
vira lata
aquela síndrome que falar por lá na zona
sul tem aqui não tem isso aqui foi cara
ou frequentar a zona sul o que tem lá
que a gente tem aqui ea organizar
felizmente festa literária da zona oeste
ea frizzo foi fantástica porque num
evento onde o prefeito falou ó na zona
oeste o deserto cultural na cidade
nós precisamos fazer alguma coisa e
falou demonstrou os dados quando ele
desceu do palco foi a de um abraço nele
falei prefeito você é um deserto eu
tenho as falei para frizzo isso aquilo
outro
eu contei pra ele a gente vai estar em
tantos bairros pois bem a prefeitura
acreditou e investiu no projeto
revelamos o lado o outro lado da cidade
maravilhosa
as maravilhas de uma cidade para bem
para além da vieira souto e da
sernambetiba e o próprio rio se
maravilhou de conhecer tanta gente boa
de tanta criação tanta criatividade ea
frizzo foi escuta
ouvimos ou vemos ouvimos todos os
bairros universidades escolas e
comunidades bairros de classe média da
própria região e mostrar uma diversidade
do nosso território
no ano seguinte e em 2013 no ano
seguinte a gente chegou a partir da
escuta e foi criar projetos e programas
de aprofundamento
foi quando criamos o de o projeto
palavras que libertam eu fui pra dentro
do sistema socioeducativo para mostrar
que qualquer pessoa pode ser escritor
que qualquer pessoa que tem uma história
pode ser inspirador
e aí as pessoas aqueles meninos eles em
dez minutos
em 30 minutos passavam escrever as suas
primeiras estrofes simplesmente que eu
chegava pra eles em falar avó racionais
a poesia um funk a poesia tira letra e
melodia e só fica letra e assim a gente
começou a criar referências dentro do do
sistema ea gente começou a levar os
meninos pra fora para visitar outros
espaços inclusive o corcovado e foi
inspirador e para encerrar o ted o x da
questão desse ted a respiração
então eu queria que vocês saírem daqui
mas não deixarem de olhar para quem está
a seu lado esquerdo direito e que está
atrás de você porque são um momento
marcante o momento inspirador e
inspiração provoca referências nenhum
sem a gente saber hoje pais mães querem
que seus filhos sejam como nós e aí cada
um que passou por aqui que vai passar
ainda inspira desde ontem estou muito
feliz aqui
e para encerrar eu vou mandar pra vocês
inspira e vocês mandam premiação fechou
assim o vamos fazer só um ensaio nem
inspira beleza vocês tão bom para
caramba logo de cara então vamos lá três
vezes só pra poder gente acaba inspira
inspira expira a inspiração que a gente
precisa josé
valeu valeu mesmo